long arms high release point on his shot
he can just raise up and
shoot over any defender morant hangs and
hits
the ball moves side to side around the
horn
williamson wants to take it at conchar
and does for two and a foul
zion williamson athletic play
from the colbert health and safety
protocols there's 22 points
13 rebounds a game
williamson attacking the rim with force
misses on the banker
adams clears
[Applause]
oh look out zion williamson
15 points and 16 minutes for heart roll
to the rim
tillman kicks it out five to shoot
oh that's a long ball job
a deep one
zion williamson yes you're correct
and one and then zion has had his way
with the memphis defense
no foul called it is scooped up by lewis
off the turnover oh look out
zion williamson on the rack attack
incredible you're right i mean they have
owned them in in part because of this
play right here
[Applause]
off the glass this is a big time shot
right here
being able to make that right there and
their offense as you can see
it's pretty pretty quite pretty
incredible
locomotive zion williamson who's going
to get in his way
not the christmas marant
continuation iron eagle along with
two-time national aau champion grant
hill
120-99
bringing out some nasty stuff
there must be something to that red clay
in south carolina
because john moran explosive
i mean he's a little guy six two six
three and his former teammate